donald trump unter druck in den usa
wollen die demokraten den präsidenten
noch vor dem 20
januar absetzen hoffnungsschimmer aus
dem labor der biontech pfizer impfstoff
wirkt offenbar auch gegen die neuartigen
virus mutationen kritische coruna lage
in london durch neue rekordzahlen droht
den krankenhäusern der collax
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am freitag und
auch norbert lehmann ist wieder dabei
für den sport ein stück von mir
nach dem angriff auf das kapitol in
washington durch einen aufgesetzten mob
bringen die demokraten auf die sofortige
absetzung von noch-präsident trump
schwierig in der kurzen zeit doch wenn
es gelänge könnte trump in vier jahren
nicht mehr zurückkommen
inzwischen gibt es ein weiteres fünftes
todesopfer ein polizist erlag seinen
verletzungen
in washington heute das capitol
abgeriegelt von der nationalgarde und
die große frage wie geht es weiter mit
dem mann der noch im weißen haus regiert
donald trump verurteilte jetzt die
gewalt seiner anhänger
doch um den präsidenten wird es immer
einsamer aus den usa berichtet britta
jäger eine videobotschaft aus dem weißen
haus
darin ein präsident der den
bevorstehenden machtwechsel zum ersten
mal öffentlich akzeptiert und die gewalt
am kapitol verurteilt neue regierung
wird am 20 januar eingeschworen
wie alle amerikaner bin ich bestürzt
über die gewalt die gesetzlosigkeit und
das chaos an die das gesetz gebrochen
haben ihr werdet bezahlen
nach den angriffen auf das kapitol vom
präsidenten provoziert werden auch die
rufe einiger republikaner lauter schon
vorzeitig aus dem weißen haus zu werfen
es steht außer frage dass amerika besser
dran wäre wenn der präsident
zurücktreten oder aus dem amt entfernt
werden würde
der wohl schnellste weg kabinett und
vizepräsident könnten trump für
amtsunfähig erklären seine absetzung
einleiten
mike pence aber verweigert einen solch
historischen schritt wohl auch mit blick
auf seine eigene politische zukunft
die demokraten wollen trumps vorzeitigen
abgang trotzdem durchdrücken
wenn es stimmt dass my pants seinen
amtseid nicht erfüllt also die
demokratie durch die absetzung des
präsidenten nicht beschützt dann werden
wir ein amtsenthebungsverfahren
einleiten
nach dem gewaltausbruch starb nun auch
ein polizist der von trump anhängern
attackiert und verletzt worden war
für ihn hängt die fahne am capitol auf
halbmast
unterdessen twitter trump er werde an
joe biden amtseinführung nicht
teilnehmen im video gibt er einen
ausblick in die zukunft an alle meine
wunderbaren anhänger ich weiß ihr seid
enttäuscht aber ich will auch dass ihr
wisst unsere unglaubliche reise hat
gerade erst begonnen
mit donald trump ist weiterhin zu
rechnen lautet die botschaft auch wenn
er hier in zwölf tagen aussieht
ines trams in washington wie ordnen sie
den champs videobotschaft ein tramp
räumt erstmals öffentlich ein dass es ab
dem 20 januar eine andere regierung eine
neue regierung geben wird mehr aber auch
nicht das ist keine kein klares
eingeständnis einer niederlage erwähnt
den namen joe biden beispielsweise ja
überhaupt nicht flach und emotionslos
trägt er die worte vor die gesamte
botschaft die gesamte video botschaft
wirkt wie aus der geiselhaft als wäre er
gezwungen worden
diese worte vorzutragen entsprechend
halte ich sie auch nicht für glaubwürdig
ich denke wir haben da den teleprompter
präsidenten trump erlebt nicht den
wahren
donald trump der redet und wütet wie er
will
doch das kann sich ganz schnell auch
wieder drehen trump scheint realisiert
zu haben er steht unter druck deswegen
wollte er zum jetzigen zeitpunkt diese
friedfertigen worte in die welt senden
dass er nun bekannt gegeben hat nicht an
der feierlichen amtsübergabe für joe
biden teilnehmen zu wollen ist ein
weiteres zeichen dafür dass er seine
niederlage nicht wirklich anerkennt das
ist ein affront gegenüber seinem
nachfolger er bricht mit der tradition
und insofern kann ich mir vorstellen
dass wir in den verbleibenden zwölf
tagen
doch auch wieder den alten den wahren
donald trump
ihnen werden vielen dank für die
einschätzung eines nach waschen zum
thema corona da gibt es ja selten gute
nachrichten doch heute haben wir drei
die wichtigste
der impfstoff von biontech weise wirkt
wohl auch bei den aggressiveren
mutierten viren sodann hat die eu noch
einmal zusätzliche impfdosen bestellt
wovon auch deutschland profitiert und
drittens darf ab sofort aus einem
biontech fläschchen eine dosis mehr
entnommen werden christoph distel ein
kühllastwagen mit polizeischutz kommt an
viel aufwand für drei pappkartons mit
jeder menge isoliermaterial trockeneis
und ja auch impfstoff mehr wagen für
deutschland sollen es werden mehr
impfstoff und so wird es auch kommen 300
millionen dosen hat sich die eu gerade
von beyond advisor zusätzlich gesichert
und ich freue mich besonders dass wir
die ersten 75 millionen dieser
bestellung schon im zweiten quartal
dieses jahres bekommen werden dazu kommt
ab heute darf jeder ampulle ergiebiger
seien sechs statt der zunächst erlaubten
fünf dosen geht in ordnung sagt die
europäische arzneimittelagentur ema
macht zusammen 20 prozent mehr impfungen
möglich und wo die wichtigste meldung
des tages dieser impfstoff kommt auch
gut gegen die neuen hochansteckenden
virus varianten aus großbritannien und
südafrika an
zumindest in vitro bei ersten tests die
serien von 20 teilnehmern der bereits
veröffentlichten phase-3-studie
neutralisierten das virus mit der
mutation im gleichen ausmaß wie das
virus ohne die mutation und zwar
deswegen beide neue mutationen betreffen
vor allem die stacheln des corona virus
dort sollen eigentlich die antikörper
von geimpften andocken und so das virus
außer gefecht setzen die gefahr nach
einer mutation die antikörper könnten
die veränderte doch stelle nicht mehr
erkennen dass sie es bis jetzt noch tun
liegt grob gesagt daran
der stachel das bike protein hat sich
zwar in teilen verändert aber doch noch
so viele bleibende merkmale dass die
antikörper ihren weg finden
als er mal ein wort teils schreiben
würde dass bestimmte buchstaben und
zusagen fielen aber wir müssen trotzdem
welches wort es ist und genauso ist es
bei ihnen antikörper an
und selbst wenn das virus radikalen
mutieren würde
fachleute meinen mit der neuen m rna
methode wäre auch dass kein schwerer
rückschlag
der vorteil eines mr anna impfstoffes
ist dass man diese mutationen sehr sehr
schnell in eine neue messenger rna
einbauen kann und dann entsprechend eben
einen neuen impfstoff zur verfügung
stellt der denn analog mit dem ersten
impfstoff zusätzlich vertieft werden
kann
immer mehr impfstoff unterwegs und
virusvarianten kommt er auch noch auf
die spur
biologen nennen das gute nachrichten in
der zweiten corona welle sterben
deutlich mehr menschen als in der ersten
im frühjahr
seit anfang dezember hat sich die zahl
der in verbindung mit dem virus
gestorbenen etwa verdoppelt und auch
heute gibt es einen traurigen höchstwert
innerhalb von 24 stunden wurden 1188
todesfälle in verbindung mit dem virus
gemeldet so viele wie noch nie
31 1849 neue infektionen wurden
registriert wegen der feiertage sind die
zahlen aber noch nicht vollständig
aussagekräftig eltern die arbeiten und
kinder die zu hause betreut werden
sollen das ist für viele familien eine
herausforderung während corona
insbesondere bei kleinen kindern
und so haben in allen bundesländern die
kitas weiter irgendwie geöffnet einige
bieten nur für dringende fälle eine
notbetreuung an andere lassen die kitas
prinzipiell offen appellieren aber an
die eltern die kinder zu hause zu lassen
wie das in hamburg funktioniert hat sich
martin niesen angeschaut
im minutentakt geben eltern ihre kinder
in der kita ab zwar sollen auch in
hamburg kinder zuhause bleiben doch die
kitas sind im eingeschränkten
regelbetrieb wie es die zuständige
sozialbehörde nennt für ausnahmefälle
viele eltern sind aber schon jetzt im
ausnahmezustand der shutdown eine art
marathon
im gegensatz zum marathon weiß man hier
nicht von das ende ist und bei einem
richtigen marathon kann man seine kräfte
einteilen und ich glaube dass jetzt
schon viele familien am ende ihrer
kräfte sind ich habe gebrochenen fuß und
drei kleine kinder unter 5 zu hause und
das stellt mich natürlich schon vor eine
große herausforderung und so allein zu
lassen das funktioniert einfach nicht
dass es beim ersten mal ja schon so
schief gegangen von 8 bis 15 uhr gilt
das betreuungsangebot wenn eltern einen
arbeitsnachweis erbringen
in dieser kita führt das zu einer
auslastung von über 50 prozent und für
die betreiber zu der frage nach dem
schutz der mitarbeitenden deswegen der
große appell fangt an die erzieherinnen
und die erzieher frühzeitig zu impfen
damit sie den kindern in den kitas zur
verfügung stehen auf eine schnelle
lösung nach die behörde allerdings wenig
hoffnung erzieherinnen und erzieher
kommen in der im freien folge an dritter
stelle
allerdings muss man dazu sagen in aller
ehrlichkeit der zeitpunkt zu dem für
diese gruppe dann impfung angeboten
werden dürfte noch etliche wochen
wahrscheinlich monate in der zukunft
liegen es bleibt schwierig für alle
kitas eltern kinder aus london kommt
heute eine dramatische warnung der
bürgermeister fürchtet einen baldigen
kollaps des gesundheitssystems
die währungskrise wütet in seiner stadt
ganz besonders heftig inzwischen meldet
die britische metropole in einer woche
1000 neue infektionen pro 100000
einwohner
die behörden haben heute nachmittag eine
sogenannte großlage ausgerufen um den
vielen corona patienten besser helfen zu
können
aus london andreas stamm
schwere fälle im stundentakt corona
patienten fluten londons krankenhäuser
rund 800 sind es allein an diesem tag
das entspricht der kapazität eines
großkrankenhauses eines wie das
university college hospital fast alle
auf der intensivstation machen extra
schichten um den ansturm zu bewältigen
tränen der verzweiflung bei einer
schwester der op umfunktioniert zur
intensivstation auch die kinderklinik
noch eine woche so weiter dann komme der
kollaps kommt es dazu können wir
niemanden mehr intensiv medizinisch
behandeln egal ob verkehrsunfall
herzinfarkt oder schlaganfall
nichts ging mehr draußen vor der
notaufnahme stauen sich krankenwagen
täglich 5000 einsätze werden in london
normalerweise gefahren momentan fast
9000 feuerwehrleute polizisten sollen
als fahrer aushelfen
das ermöglicht der beschluss des
bürgermeisters der am mittag für die
hauptstadt eine notlage ausruft
ich bin besorgt darüber dass das virus
außer kontrolle ist das in wochen oder
gar tagen es keine freien
krankenhausbetten mehr geben wird und
dass aktuellen manchen gegenden londons
jeder zwanzigste infiziert ist
die regierung setzt alles auf impfen ein
dritter impfstoff der von moderner
erhält heute ebenfalls einen notfall
zulassung zwei millionen impfungen pro
woche wie schwer das ist erlebt der
gesundheitsminister hautnah beim
fototermin in einer klinik fehlt der
impfstoff lieferprobleme wertvolle zeit
verloren während die uhr tickt im kampf
den kollaps von londons krankenhäusern
zu verhindern
in der ganzen welt hat corona vieles
verändert in der zdf- heute- app werfen
wir einen blick darauf wie sich die
pandemie auf unsere sprache auswirkt ein
spannender einblick zum durchklicken
bei der cdu hat ja corona die suche nach
einem neuen vorsitzenden ordentlich
durcheinandergewirbelt
nun aber läuft der countdown für den
weitgehend digitalen parteitag ende
nächster woche
seit ein paar minuten stellen sich die
drei kandidaten noch einmal online den
fragen von mitgliedern für norbert
röttgen armin laschet und friedrich merz
geht es um die nachfolge von annegret
kramp karrenbauer
erst einmal ja und die frage an gunther
love energy in berlin wer hat den
inzwischen die nase vorn kann man das
irgendwie schon erahnen
also keiner so weit dass er schon
aufatmen könnte in jüngeren umfragen
führt friedrich merz knapp in der aller
jüngsten die die ard kollegen gestern
veröffentlicht haben liegt dabei cdu
anhängern mit 29 prozent vorne aber ganz
dicht gefolgt sowohl von armin laschet
als auch norbert röttgen die gleichauf
mit 25 prozent dahinter liegen also ein
noch ganz völlig offenes rennen und man
muss auch dazu sagen cdu anhänger sind
nicht diejenigen die dann am ende den
cdu vorsitzenden wählen das sind die cdu
die die parteitagsdelegierten 1001 und
die müssen überzeugt werden in normalen
zeiten würden dass die kandidaten direkt
vor ort machen und zwar sehr massiv das
geht jetzt nicht so muss alles virtuell
passieren man muss jede gelegenheit
nutzen und eine solche gelegenheit ist
das was heute hier hinter mir in der
parteizentrale passiert ja dann gibt es
ja noch die k frage wer soll
kanzlerkandidat werden
ja richtig das macht das ganze noch
einmal komplizierter denn wenn man sich
da die umfragen anschaut dann liegt
keiner der drei kandidaten die im rennen
sind in allen umfragen vorne da gibt es
da gibt es zwei andere die sich da
heraus stellen
markus söder aus bayern wird er immer
wieder genannt als geeigneter kandidat
aber auch jens spahn der
gesundheitsminister der hier im team mit
armin laschet antritt und dem gerade
jetzt nachgesagt wird dass er selber
schon mal die fühler ausstreckt wieder
in seine chancen danach stehen er selbst
weist das zurück man sieht an dieser
ganzen situation wie nervös die cdu hier
insgesamt ist und wie viele gedanken man
sich darüber macht wie dieses rennen
wohl ausgeht keiner hat so ein richtiges
gefühl momentan ein spannendes jahr
vielen dank internet auch die spd steht
vor herausforderungen welche akzente
will man setzen im jahr der
bundestagswahl
wie will man punkten beim wähler all das
muss besprochen werden den anfang macht
die fraktion in berlin sie traf sich zu
ihrer jahresauftaktklausur und der
kanzlerkandidat war auch dabei lars boom
sagt berichtet olaf scholz übt schon mal
die kanzlei rotter trotz weiter eher
mauen umfragezahlen glaubt er
kandidat der spd unbeirrt an einen
erfolg bei der bundestagswahl
wir spielen auf sieg es geht darum diese
wahl zu gewinnen und das werden wir tun
indem wir unseren plan entwickeln der
für die zukunft deutschlands im
kommenden jahrzehnt entscheidend ist zu
diesem plan gehört dass die genossen
künftig eine deutlich soziale politik
durchsetzen wollen und hoffen dabei auf
ein linkes regierungsbündnis unter ihrer
führung mit den cdu kandidaten sehen sie
keine gemeinsame zukunft erkennbar ist
dass die drei bewerber um den vorsitz
der cdu auf dieser welle schwimmen dass
es nach corona eine finanzielle
vollbremsung geben muss dass wir nicht
nur wahlweise sondern sowohl als auch
auf soziale sicherung wie auch auf
investitionen verzichten müssten das ist
nicht unsere sichtweise tatsächlich
setzt sich die spd bereits jetzt schon
von der union ab die sozialdemokraten
wollen keine bewaffnung von drohnen
drängen darauf sich mehr von den usa
abzukoppeln und lassen in sachen
impfstoff beschaffung gegenüber dem
gesundheitsminister nicht locker wir
haben am wochenende noch mal sehr klar
und sehr deutlich gemacht dass wir
letztlich auch mehr erwarten deswegen
hat offensichtlich ja auch die
bundeskanzlerin die konsequenzen gezogen
und diese frage an den
kabinettsausschuss und ganz konkret an
sie heran gezogen und das nicht mehr
allein dem gesundheitsminister sparen
überlassen regierungsverantwortung
tragen und gleichzeitig den
koalitionspartner angreifen
das superwahljahr fordert von der spd
einen politischen spagat beim nachwuchs
der spd gab es heute eine wichtige
personalentscheidung jessica rosenthal
ist neue bundesvorsitzende der jusos sie
tritt die nachfolge von kevin kühnert an
der inzwischen stellvertretender
parteivorsitzender ist und in den
bundestag will jessica rosenthal ist 28
jahre alte lehrerin und war bislang juso
chefin in nordrhein westfalen
und dann gab es heute noch diese zahl in
deutschland sind im vergangenen jahr so
wenige neue autos zugelassen worden wie
seit zehn jahren nicht mehr
insgesamt waren es zwei
zwei millionen gut 19 prozent weniger
als im jahr zuvor
deutlich nach oben zeigte trend dagegen
bei reinen elektroautos knapp 195.000
neuzulassungen bedeuten ein plus von
mehr als 200 prozent
dennoch liegt ihr anteil auf
deutschlands straßen immer noch bei nur
1,2 prozent ja und nun zu dir norbert
und zur tour de ski in val die firma ja
und da lief es gut für die deutschen
langläuferinnen und langläufer janosch
brugger mit einem starken sechsten platz
ja und bei den frauen glänzte katharina
hennig beim 10 kilometer massenstart
holte sie platz zwei ihr bestes weltcup
ergebnis überhaupt
am ort ihres ersten weltcup podiums vor
genau einem jahr zeigt sich hennig
erneut in bestform
von beginn an in der spitzengruppe kommt
sie gemeinsam mit der russischen freie
war und der schwedin anders sondern über
den letzten anstieg nur eine freie weist
schneller als katharina heinig diese
lässt anders an hinter sich massenstart
klassische technik so etwas liebt die 24
jahre alte langläuferin aus dem
erzgebirge in der gesamtwertung
verbessert sich hennig damit vom neunten
auf den fünften platz
kein guter tag dagegen für die dsv
biathleten beim weltcup in oberhof bei
den frauen als beste deutsche franziska
preuß auf platz 14 bei den männern
benedikt doll als fünfzehnter am morgen
das bundesliga-topspiel leipzig gegen
dortmund für rb heißt es gewinnen um an
tabellenführer bayern dran zu bleiben
für den bvb gewinnen um nicht den
anschluss an das spitzen trio zu
verlieren
für hummels mukoko und co geht es
samstag gegen die sachsen mal wieder
mehr zu zeigen von dem was sie drauf
haben
leipzig wird sicherlich ein gradmesser
für uns müssen absolut eine gute
leistung bringen denn ansonsten werden
wir dort nicht so denn kontrahent
leipzig ist derzeit kaum zu halten
die rasenballer sportlich immer stärker
großes selbstvertrauen inklusive den sie
gar nicht schon ein weil wir mutig genug
sind wir sehr gut drauf sind wir eine
tolle statistik haben in der liga was
die defensive aber auch gerade dass die
heimstärke angeht haben wir neun punkte
vorsprung das er natürlich schon ein
sehr guter schritt gingen direkten
konkurrenten leipzig gegen dortmund und
die frage wer besser vorankommt am
samstag wird sich zeigen
das topspiel morgen abend ausführlich
bei uns aktuelle sportstudio 23 uhr dann
genau morgen schneit es noch ein wenig
im osten sonst zeigt sich auch mal die
sonne
das wochenendwetter gleich von katja
honnefer das war es von uns für heute
schön dass sie dabei waren
marietta slomka erwartet sie heute um 10
im heute-journal und uns gibt es morgen
wieder punkt 19 uhr einen schönen abend
wünschen wie chips
[Musik]
knaben meine damen und herren so von
oben betrachtet sehen tannenspitzen von
schnee bedeckt doch einfach nur bizarr
raus und schnee fiel heute ganz
verbreiteten auch heute nacht fällt noch
schnee besonders im osten an der
ostseeküste ist auch noch ein bisschen
regen dabei machen sie sich überall
wieder auf straßenglätte gefasst auch
die gehwege könnten glatt sein
bei tiefsttemperaturen zwischen 1 grad
auf rügen und minus 15 grad am alpenrand
morgen pendeln die werte dann wieder um
den gefrierpunkt am kühlsten platz an
den alpen mit minus 4 grad am mildesten
wird auf den ostfriesischen inseln mit
plus 4 grad und auch morgen gibt es noch
einige schneeschauer zum beispiel im
südlichen brandenburg auch in sachsen
und in den westlichen mittelgebirgen
zwischen sylt und dem ruhrgebiet kommt
dagegen die sonne mal zum vorschein
genauso wie am oberrhein und südlich der
donau am sonntag und am montag ändert
sich an diesem wetter noch ein wenig bei
höchsttemperaturen von minus fünf bis
plus fünf grad aber am dienstag da dreht
der wind dann auf nordwest und dann
kommen neue schnee und schneeregen
wolken heran und dann gibt's
winterwetter der eher unangenehmen sorte
schön ab